MALE SPEAKER: Today with
us is Neil Davies, who
co-authored the book "Biocode."
The living world runs
on genomics software.
Genomes can now be sequenced
rapidly and increasingly
cheaply.
The genomes of large
numbers of organisms,
from mammals to microbes,
have been mapped.
Getting your genome sequenced
is becoming affordable for many.
The ability to read
DNA has changed
how we view ourselves and
understand our place in nature.
So this is a great book to
get into the meaning and uses
and all of the new advances
in genomics science.
It was written by Dawn
Field, senior research fellow
at Oxford e-Research Center,
and by our guest today,
Neil Davies, executive director
of the UC Berkeley Gump South
Pacific Research Station.
Neil Davies lives on
Moorea, the sister island
to Tahiti in French Polynesia.
He's the lead
principal investigator
of the Moorea Barcode
Project, a $5 million
effort to sequence DNA barcodes
on all known microbial species
on the island.
Both are research associates
of the Biovidersity Institute
of Oxford, where they are using
their complementary experiences
to co-found the International
Genomic Observations Network.
They have published
between them more than 140
scientific articles,
including in science, nature,
nature genetics, nature
biotechnology, nature methods,
and PNAS.
PNAS stands for?
NEIL DAVIES: Proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences.
MALE SPEAKER: OK,
I didn't know that.
And they have both
research interests
in evolution, populational
genetics, genomics,
metagenomics, DNA barcoding,
bioinformatics, biodiversity,
and data sharing.
Please join me in welcoming
Neil Davies to Google today.
NEIL DAVIES: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much,
and it's a pleasure
to be here just to talk a little
bit about our work, of course
to talk about this
book, which we'll cover,
which really if anything,
is a homage to DNA,
a truly remarkable molecule.
Since the origin of the
universe and then the earth,
DNA appeared, as far as we
know, for the first time
on this planet about
four billion years ago
and eventually led to us.
And this had many
consequences and will continue
to have a lot of consequences.
You can see what this
molecule has done.
We humans have seen it from
outer space looking back.
That is the phenotype, the
expression of this molecule.
Because the Earth is really
fashioned to a large extent
by the activity that resulted
from DNA, initially from,
again, as far as we
know, one single molecule
that miraculously
appeared on Earth
about four billion years ago.
And we represent
continuous family
descended from that
molecule and the first cell.
And then more recently to our
little tiny sliver of time
here in modern days, covering
this 300-year period,
back in 1769 when
people like Captain Cook
was out exploring
the planet, and
the first coordinated
scientific global mission
occurred back then to
observe the transit of Venus.
100 years later, DNA
was first recognized.
100 years after that, DNA had
got to the moon, thanks to us.
Or it took us to the moon.
We took it to the moon.
And 100 years from now,
we're suddenly already
in the Anthropocene in
that we, DNA through us,
is really changing the
world in a major way.
And we don't quite know what
2069 is going to look like.
And that's part of what
I'm going to address
in this presentation.
But there's lots of
technologies that are evolving,
but our particular focus here is
the truly spectacular advances
of genomic technologies,
which of course go along
with the plummeting price
of what it costs now
to read DNA sequences.
So you've probably
all seen these kinds
of graphs before
based on Moore's Law
and genomic sequencing, which
really obviously derives
largely from the
advances in computing
in the first place, which
has made this possible.
It shows that the cost of
getting your genome sequenced
is heading down to $1,000
and soon below that.
And the consequences
of that for humans--
we're going to be sequencing
ourselves, many times
over probably, and
some projections
of how many human genomes
may be sequenced by 2024
are in the billions.
So again, this is the
usual exponential growth
in technology.
But what are the impacts
of this going to be
on us, on our personal health?
But also, because
DNA is universal.
Everything living, as
far as we know, has DNA.
And it's a standardized code.
It's the same code.
So whatever was developed
to read our genomes
works in everything else.
So we're able to leverage
the advances driven primarily
by medicine, and we
can read genomes now
in every other species on Earth.
And that's really in my
personal interest, is of course
an interest in the health
of humans, too, but also,
what about all the other
species, of which, of course,
we humans depend upon.
So our ability to read
DNA has advanced massively
but including up to
the point now where
we can start to write
that code as well.
And this is in many ways
an even bigger shift.
We can understand, we can
see what nature has done,
but now we have this God-like
capacity where we can actually
potentially create life.
We can certainly modify it.
And that's the first time
in four billion years
that anyone else has been
shaping our biological future.
So this is the first
time we can potentially
start a new tree of life
synthetically, which
would be the first time
in four billion years
and in the universe,
as far as we know,
the only other time that
that's been possible.
So that should at least give
us a little pause of thought,
the consequences of
that philosophically
as well as practically.
So DNA is everywhere now.
You read about DNA all the time.
And has all kinds of
benefits and impacts
of what we can do with
this new-found capacity.
So here's just several
articles showing
some of the applications of
DNA sequencing technologies.
And they're obviously
far beyond medicine.
Dawn Field, if
you're interested,
follow her blog here.
She keeps up to date on
some of these advances
from across these broad
range of applications.
So I encourage you to
have a look at that,
at her blog there.
But today I'm going to talk
more about specifically
about biodiversity genomics
and some of the work
that I'm personally
more involved in
and particularly how we take
this understanding of genomics,
apply it to other
species, and ultimately
to ecosystems to
really start to build
a computational model of place.
I'll explain what
I mean by that.
Essentially, you want to built
avatars, not just of ourselves,
but of the places
we live in, so we
can perform some of the
scientific experiments
that we need to be
able to do if we're
going to understand
how to manage
our ecosystems in the future.
But of course we can't do
them in the real world because
of temporal and ethical
and other concerns.
So we really have to
do them in silico.
It's our only option.
Like global climate
modeling, we have
to rely on computer models,
because we only have
one Earth to experiment on.
So the Earth is, I think
Carl Sagan described it,
a pale blue dot in
the darkness of space.
And it is our island home.
And when we look at it,
we see this is an island,
and we really need to take
care of the island we live on.
This view on Google Earth--
so I'm happy to be here--
is centered on Oxford, which
is where I'm originally from.
And I moved in 2000 to
Tahiti in French Polynesia.
[LAUGHTER]
And really, I have to say,
Google does fantastic things,
and Google Earth is-- everyone
says maps and seeing things
changes your perspective.
I had no idea where
I was living until I
played with Google Earth.
And so I was thinking,
oh, this is going
to be fun to see where we are.
I knew I was in the middle
of the Pacific Ocean,
but I had no idea quite how
big the Pacific Ocean was.
And I think-- maybe
someone here can
test this-- what view, if
you send to Google Earth,
where do you see the most ocean?
This is centered on Moorea.
I suspect it's pretty close.
I don't know exactly
what the point is.
As an anecdote, I was
in Hawaii, where I lived
prior to moving to Tahiti.
But I went back there
a few months ago,
and I was in a taxi.
And the taxi driver said,
oh, where are you from?
I said, well, I live in Tahiti.
He said, oh, wow.
You live in the middle of
the ocean, huh? [LAUGHS]
[LAUGHTER]
I was on Oahu, which
for most people
is pretty much in the
middle of the ocean.
Anyhow, so the Pacific,
as recently described
in "The Economist,"
is a blank on the map
except for some little islands.
But it's bigger than the
world's entire land mass.
So the Pacific is a
pretty significant place,
even though for humans it's
been largely a blank, at least
for most humans.
But the island of Moorea,
where the research station
is located, is part
of French Polynesia,
which is an overseas
territory, a country of France.
It has five million
square kilometers
of exclusive economic zone.
So it's a big footprint on the
Earth that's controled there
by French Polynesia.
The island of Moorea
is unusual, in that it
has two international
research stations located
on it, UC Berkeley, also the
French [INAUDIBLE] National
Lab on the same island.
So here we are located on
the North Shore of Moorea.
And we formed a
partnership along
with a number of
other institutions
to really try and study this
island in a lot of detail.
So the Criobe, the French lab,
has been there since 1971,
primarily studying coral
reefs, which makes these coral
reefs probably the
longest studied anywhere
in the world continuously.
The Berkeley station
was established in 1985.
So we're celebrating
our 30 years.
It was donated by
Mr. Richard Gump,
who was from San Francisco,
Gump's department store.
You may have seen it.
And we've had a lot
of support from Gordon
Moore and the Gordon and Betty
Moore Foundation since then,
including building
the laboratories
and funding some of the research
programs I'll talk about.
Finally, we now have another.
Just off the coast of
Moorea is a small atoll,
which used to be
owned by Marlon Brando
and is currently owned
by the Brando estate.
And there, we have a
partnership with an eco resort,
and we have a small research
station on this atoll.
So we have a high
island and an atoll
very close to one
another, so two
very exceptional natural
research laboratories for work.
So I'm going to just give
a little bit of context
on these islands, because
I'm going to come back
to them later in the talk.
But as I say, we have
this scale of complexity
from a small private island with
a couple hundred people on it
to Moorea, 17,000 people.
And it's a populated place
with agriculture and fisheries
and everything else
that a society has.
And then next door
is Tahiti, which
has 200,000 people and
a jump up in complexity.
The other interesting
thing scientifically
to know about these islands,
and this applies similarly
to the Hawaiian Islands,
they're on hotspot archipelagos.
So you have the younger
island down here in the south.
And as the Pacific plate
moves up to the northwest,
the islands move
off the hot spot.
And so they get older.
So Moorea is a little
bit older than Tahiti.
Tahiti is the youngest island
still close to the hot spot.
Bora Bora up there
in the Northwest
is a much older island.
So we have this
great time machine
ready to move back
and forth in time,
say, what will Tahiti look
like in a few million years.
Well, we can go up the
island chain and see that.
And Hawaii is a similar case.
So it's truly
remarkable for people
studying evolutionary ecology.
Because we don't
have a time ship,
and we're working on these
kinds of times scales.
Our processes take that long.
So it's very hard for us
to do any experimentation.
But here provides a
nice comparative setup.
You couldn't really
ask for better.
So that's Moorea today.
Moorea in 3 million years is
going to look something like,
which is, in fact, Bora Bora.
And in 5 million years,
it will look something
like this, an atoll.
The important part as a
natural system for study
is that we're at this end of a
natural biodiversity gradient.
So the highest
biodiversity in the world
is out in Southeast Asia.
This is marine and terrestrial.
As you come across
the South Pacific,
there's a gradual
attenuation in biodiversity.
Interesting, that also
applies to human culture.
There's 900 or so languages
in Papua New Guinea.
Once you get out to
eastern Polynesia,
there's one clade,
one family of people,
the Polynesians,
who have spread out
to 50 different ethnographically
described societies,
from Easter Island, New
Zealand, up to Hawaii,
and Tahiti in the middle.
So it's one monophyletic
group that's down here, so low
cultural diversity
compared to the West.
And these systems have
gone through the evolution
that a lot of societies
have around the world.
But the difference
is here the epochs
are very clearly demarcated.
So the island arose in
the middle of the ocean.
There was no one there.
All the plants and animals
has to colonize that island.
So there was a pre-human period.
And then these are
last places on Earth
to be colonized by
humans, Polynesians
arriving about 1,500 years ago.
So it's relatively very recent.
Of course, when
Polynesians arrived,
that was a huge impact that came
with plants and other animals
and insects and led to
a complete overhaul,
collapse of the system
and then a reformulation
of a new ecological system, so
an example of complex system
cycles.
And then that reached
some kind of stability,
at least over the 1,000
years or so of Polynesians
there until-- and this
we know to the day--
until the first European
explorers arrived
in Tahiti in 1767.
And that was also a massive
upheaval of the system,
mainly, at least
for the human part,
is due to introductions of
new biodiversity, new genomes,
in the form of infectious
diseases, which led
to a crash in the population.
And then the fourth
one is really
when the islands were
connected to the modern world.
And that started
in around the 1960s
with the first
international airport.
And mainly that was initiated
through nuclear testing
that the French were
carrying out at that time.
So each of these
phases really is
marked by a great
increasing in connectivity.
And these islands
became less of islands.
And of course today,
the big change
is we may be in the
fifth epoch, which
is driven by the internet.
So a few years ago,
French Polynesia
laid a submarine cable
between Tahiti and Hawaii
for the first time.
So now there's fiber
optic connection
to the Hawaiian
Islands, and of course
from Hawaii to the mainland.
And so we have now
these two archipelagos
on either side of
the equator connected
on a backbone of
fiber optic, which
is having social consequences.
But for us scientifically,
this is a great thing.
So now we're connected
to the rest of the world.
And we can really
study these systems
and take full advantage of
supercomputer capacities
on mainland and instantaneous
communications, high bandwidth.
So I'm going to talk in
a little more detail now
about biodiversity
specifically and how
it relates to ecosystem
services and genomics.
So this is a new panel.
You've probably all
heard of the IPCC
for climate change,
Intergovernmental
Panel on Climate Change.
This is a new one with
a similar kind of goal
but focusing on
biodiversity, because we're
facing a twin crisis.
We have climate
change, of course
by carbon emissions,
greenhouse gases.
But we also are
losing biodiversity
at a dramatic rate.
And I think not
many people argue
that that's due to humans.
We all know that human activity
obviously kills things,
sometimes deliberately.
But through land use
change and others,
clearly we're reducing
biodiversity ourselves.
And that is, in some
ways, much more worrying,
because that truly
is irreversible.
Once it's gone, we
can't get it back.
So at the research
station in Moorea,
we have conferences
on different things,
too, including astronomy.
And one of the
interesting things
I learned from a recent
astronomy conference
was talking about
the dark energy.
A lot of that is not really
known, this 70% or so
of what dark energy is.
But astronomy physicists have
this really great clarity
of view and are far ahead of
us in biodiversity science,
because that's how
it looks to us.
We have about 1.2 million
species that are cataloged.
And that's pretty good.
But really, we're seeing
things incredibly fuzzily,
because the vast majority of
species on Earth are dark.
We know they're
there, but we have
no idea what they are exactly.
So 86% of eukaryotics, of
animal and plant species,
we know, or we
estimate, are still
out there waiting to be
just described, just listed.
And at the current
rate, that's going
to take many, many, many,
many years, decades,
about 20,000 species a year.
So we're not even getting close
to challenging this problem.
And that's really literally
the tip of the iceberg,
because those are just
the animals and plants
and eukaryotic larger species.
Half of the biomass on
Earth are microbial.
And who knows how many
species of microbes there are.
And of course, as
we're learning now
through genomic,
metagenomic techniques,
we humans are largely microbial.
In some estimates, obviously
by mass we're mainly human,
we're the foundation species,
but we're a walking ecosystem,
and only one in 100 of our
cells of our bodies are human.
And even fewer of our genes
in our bodies are human genes.
So does that change the way
we think about ourselves?
I'm still who I am.
I'm still a human.
But are the microbes
part of me, too?
Yeah, they are.
Does that change the way
I think about myself?
I'm not sure yet.
I'm still thinking about it.
But definitely if we want
to understand our health,
we need to understand
the ecological health
of our communities.
And that's one of the main
messages we try and get
across in the book.
We have to think that
we're all ecosystems now.
And we need ecosystem thinking,
which medicine hasn't really
had to deal with in the past.
So the idea that we
can study biodiversity
on Earth, which is
undoubtedly vitally
important to the health of
the planet and ourselves,
just studying this little bit,
the vertebrates and the plants,
is limited.
Or, as [? Bob ?] [? Robbins, ?]
who all through his slides,
[? says, ?] wrong.
We really have to
look at the whole.
Because a lot of the important
processes that are happening on
the planet are being carried
out by these microbes,
including the processes
happening inside us.
Fortunately, of course,
seems like we've
got an overwhelming task, but
technology comes to our aid
here and the exponential
increase in the DNA
technologies, particularly.
What that's meaning
is that this challenge
of documenting, at least
in the first stage,
and then understanding what
all this biodiversity is
doing before it disappears,
is possible now.
At least we can hope to get
there, thanks to genomics
and, as I said before, because
DNA is a universal code,
thank God.
If DNA wasn't, and we had to
do the code of the Human Genome
Project for every
species, we'd be toast.
I mean, there's no way we
could get funding to that
for every species, right?
But it was done for
the humans, and now we
can apply that everywhere else.
So we're really able
to piggyback on that,
and it's not a
coincidence, of course.
It's because it is the standard
code, because life did only
evolve once.
So we are truly all related.
And that's what's giving
us these new tools.
We're not quite at the
point where you can just
squash something
on your smartphone
and you get back
all the information.
But we're getting close, closer.
An initiative here of
identifying one standard gene
region that if we sequence them
for a representative species,
we have a species name,
we can use that tag
as the identifier for
any bit of biomaterial.
If you have the material, you
can sequence it very cheaply,
possibly even just squash
it on your phone one day,
reference a database, and get
back what that species is.
So this is the barcode concept.
The species are barcoded.
But their names, again
very conveniently for us,
are written inside them.
Our genomes are our names.
They're our full
names, and they're
written in every single cell.
So as long as we
have a cell, we can
identify what the species is.
So it couldn't have
been any easier
for taxonomists in some ways.
The answer is there
and are already
pre-labeled in all of our cells.
So the technology
is getting better,
but there are some
incompressible,
or they seem to be
uncompressible, costs.
So unfortunately, DNA
technology is very advanced.
But we can't read
it from satellites.
So to do things at
high scale, we still
have to physically go out
and get a piece of material,
biomaterial.
And these are just places
where you're trying
to do that from anywhere.
That's expensive.
Just the physical-- how
do you catch these things?
And catching them isn't easy.
They evolve to
avoid us, generally.
So that's an
uncompressible cost.
So it's still
expensive to do this,
even if the sequencing and then
the informatics and processing
get to be very, very cheap.
So we could potentially
sequence every species on Earth.
It's going to take us a long
time, mainly at least because
of those collecting costs.
So one thing we're trying
to do is fast forward
to the future of what would
it look like if we did
know all of our biodiversity?
We can't do that for the whole
planet or even a country,
but we can essentially do it
for a small island, a model
systems, as we've done
at the level of organisms
with model species like
the fruit fly or the mouse.
We've really thrown
the kitchen sink
at those species to
understand how they function.
So medicine, that approach has
been being incredibly powerful.
We've studied both
very simple species
and extremely complex ones, us.
And we've learned
a lot from studying
both of those at the same
time in a lot of detail.
So one thing we're arguing
for and promoting in this book
as well is to take that
model from medicine
and apply it at the ecosystem
and the social ecosystem scale
in these natural laboratories.
And it's really taking
the systems approach
that's been developed in
biology, systems biology,
for medicine, the sort of P4
approach, which is Predictive,
Preventative, Participatory, and
apply that to sustainability.
We have to just in
Personalizing it,
the fourth P, for ourselves,
everyone's different,
and we want to
understand ourselves
at the individual level in order
to predict and then prevent
disease as it comes along.
But to understand ourselves,
we also have to share.
It has to be participatory.
Because I might have a
sequence of my genome,
but I can't say too much about
what that will do unless I
can compare it with others.
So we have to participate
with each other
and get involved in
the science ourselves.
And that's the same at
the ecosystem scale.
Every system is completely
unique and different,
but it shares
commonalities with others.
So we need to participate,
share, but also personalize
and develop a predictive
approach, which
is very intensive.
So how do we go
about doing this?
So we're proposing this
sustainability science
approach, which explicitly
models itself on what's
been done in medicine.
Of course, we're having these
big impacts on the planet.
This isn't quite what
it looks like outside,
but it probably will do
in a couple of hours.
So we're having a big impact,
and we can see that everywhere.
So this is a Pacific
island, so very far away
from that kind of
traffic, although Honolulu
has a lot of traffic, too.
But even out in the
middle of the Pacific,
we can pick up this signal.
Of course, the
famous observations
from [INAUDIBLE] on the
concentration of carbon
dioxide, you see the
planet breathing here,
but it's going up.
So we're having impacts even
in these most remote islands,
which is showing that
through global change,
nowhere is pristine anymore.
Everywhere is impacted
by human activities.
So whereas in the past we could
manage things locally and not
have to worry about what
everyone else is doing, now
even if you're living
out where I live now,
you have to worry about
what everyone else is doing,
because even if you're
perfectly managing your system,
you're being driven from
outside forces, to which you
have to respond.
So we need a
sustainability science
that is theoretically
interesting and challenging
but is also very applied.
It needs to be actionable.
We need to come up
with recommendations
for how do we manage, how
do we adapt to change,
and how do we mitigate the
changes, if that's possible.
And that has to happen at
all these different scales,
At the global scale, certainly.
Unfortunately, on
the global scale,
we have limited
governance capacity.
At national scales, we have
a lot more levers to pull.
But also right
down to what people
really care about is what's
happening in your backyard,
how is this impacting me, which
why all politics is local.
But that's also true of
a lot of these processes.
They're happening at a
local scale, albeit driven
by global processes.
So the systems approach needs
to be both planet down--
for example, here
we have to look
at how is the ocean
becoming more acidic?
So that's happening worldwide.
It's a worldwide phenomenon
driven by worldwide processes.
But if we want to understand
how the natural world
and how societies
are going to respond,
we need to look at
that more locally,
and even to the genome.
So for example,
in corals, of you
want to know what's going
to happen to corals because
of ocean acidification, we have
to look at the calcification
process.
How does that work?
What genes are involved?
Do the corals have
any genetic variation
that enables them to
respond to different levels
of acidification and
continue to grow?
But that we have to understand
at the genome scale and all
the scales in between.
So it is the massive challenge.
We have to go from
here, molecule,
genome, particularly up,
all the way to the planet,
and understand how these
things all interact.
I mentioned the astronomers.
So this is pretty big.
But we probably don't need
to do too much astronomy,
necessarily, although
the planets certainly
are impacting us as well.
And do we need to go
to subatomic particles?
I don't know-- probably not.
But still, that leaves us
with a vast swathe to study.
So at the global scale,
there are initiatives.
This is the Group on
Earth Observations trying
to coordinate how we observe the
planet, including biodiversity,
weather patterns, climate,
physical processes.
And at the genomic
level, we've launched
a Genomic Observatories
Network, which
is partly under GEO,
and applying standards
for how we do this
so we can actually
compare the data that we're
observing in the field.
Because [? either ?]
we can get sequences,
and there are lots and lots
of sequences now in GenBank.
What's crucial to take
advantage of those sequences
is the context, the
information about where
those sequences came from.
And a lot of them
initially didn't even
have the time and a place.
And there's very little we can
do with both types of sequences
without those data.
And then there's all kinds
of other contextual data
that we need to
have if we're going
to make those sequences useful.
So because there is a cost
of collecting the sequences
and there's a cost
to analyzing them
and all of the contextual
data has much more value
if they have a rich
context, we want
to study these,
focus this sequencing
effort in places that are very
well studied across all levels.
And it has to be
focused, because it's
expensive to do this
at a high density.
So this is an example
from our site.
This is part of a network.
The National Science
Foundation in the United States
funds long-term
ecological research sites,
which are 25 sites
funded by the NSF,
which are a focused effort
on those places over decades.
So places like that
is where we can
focus these genomic
observations where
we know, then, they will be
embedded in this very, very
rich context.
And our challenge-- let's
click through those--
is how to integrate across
all of these different data
sets to address
specific processes.
So I mentioned
there are a number
of these sites around the world,
and we formed this network
trying to work together.
The genomic technologies
are evolving so fast,
there's a lot of the
participatory part, sharing
what works, what doesn't
work, because we're
building a genomic observatory,
layering it into studies that
give it the historical context.
How did we get to
this point today?
So we need the archaeological,
paleoecological work.
The environmental
observatory-- what's
the environmental context
of those sequences?
Ecological-- the classical
part of counting birds and fish
and butterflies.
But also social-- what are
humans doing in that system?
Like I said before, we
can't ignore humans anymore
in natural systems where we're
key drivers of those systems.
So we have to layer these
genomic observations
at these various levels.
And these observatories could
be at the scale of single--
sometimes they're a buoy
that's intensively monitored,
just a point.
It's obviously a
very open system,
an ecosystem not really, maybe.
People-- we're monitoring
our microbiome.
So in a sense, some of
us, some of the best
studied people are becoming
genomic observatories,
looking at how their microbiome
and how their genome changes
during their lifetime.
That's a form of
genomic observatory.
There's work going on in
buildings like a hospital,
starting from scratch as
the hospital is built.
How is it colonized by
different microbes over time?
How does that
affect the patients?
Forests are being studied,
whole river basins, up
to complete land masses,
small ones or larger ones,
and then ultimately the planet.
So one of the first
actions of this-- these
are both making
genomic observations
at a very local scale to
address local questions.
But also globally, we can start
to coordinate those and fashion
a global observatory.
And we did this under a
project called Ocean Sampling
Day, which was an
attempt to find out,
can we task the world to make a
coordinated genomic observation
using the same protocols at
the same time on the same day?
Like you would if you had
a telescope or something--
we want to run this experiment.
Can we do this?
So that we did it last year.
180 sites around
the world went out
and did exactly the same
thing on the same time.
And it was from
Antarctica to the tropics
in all these kind of
different sort of conditions.
And it was done remarkably
cheaply, on a shoestring,
basically, because
we could leverage
all of these places
that have boats,
that have people, that have
labs that are already out there.
They just need
coordination, and we can go
and start doing the same thing.
"Just" I say, because
it's a lot of work.
But the infrastructure exists.
If we want to tool it up for
something, we can use it.
So the question is, what
would we do with this capacity
that we have?
And it's just an
emerging capacity,
which we're realizing for the
first time we have the ability
to apply.
So now I'll switch a little
bit to how we use genomics
at these places and
following our roadmap here
from systems biology.
If we want to understand a
system from the genome up,
one of the first things
you need to do is ask,
what's in the system?
What are the parts?
As I mentioned
before, biodiversity
is a real challenge,
because we have no idea.
It's like you're trying
to study a car engine
and you've only got a bit
of the front headlight
and then the rear view
mirror, and you're
trying to figure out
how this car operates.
So that's a big
limitation, and we
had this project, which was
the Biocode Project, which
started on Moorea,
the goal of which
was to sequence one
example, at least,
of every species of
animal, plant, and fungi
as possible from the entire
system, from the coral reefs
about 150 meters down to 1,200
meters up on the mountaintop.
This was funded by the Gordon
and Betty Moore Foundation
and involved many,
many scientists
from a lot of institutions
around the world,
led by the ones listed here.
Then, collecting
biodiversity is messy.
There's a reason why
it's called biodiversity.
It's diverse.
There are all kinds
of variations.
So out there it's very variable,
and the collection methods, you
need specialists who know how
to go and catch these critters.
They can involve going up
at night to the mountaintops
or deep down diving
down to 150 meters
on the outer slope of the reefs.
So that's the cost part.
And then you collect
all of these organisms,
then come back to the lab,
and they look something
like this, this explosion
of tubes and taking
digital photographs
of everything, trying
to link the photographs to
make sure it all stays linked
to the specimen in the
tube, which will eventually
lead to a DNA sequence.
Of course, the sequencing
was being done mainly
at the Smithsonian
in Washington,
so those sequences
get appended later
to these data, all
the while retaining
all of the contextual
information
about where that sample came
from in the natural world.
So it's a complete explosion
of data carried out
by different people coming
from different times,
from different institutions
and different countries.
Most of the work
flow, though, starts
with this single
collecting event.
It has to be
isolated from nature.
And everything really
hangs off that.
But even before that,
you need to get a permit.
Genetic resources these
days are valuable,
and they are
increasingly regulated.
So that's a part that
can't be forgotten.
But then it generates
from that one event.
There's this cascade as
you get many specimens.
Those are photograph
they get sub-sampled
into different tubes, sent
off to different labs,
and sequenced.
And then all those data get
stored in different places
around the world.
And some of those are
physical specimens.
Many of them are
digital data items.
So how do we keep
track of all these
and keep them all
linked together?
And they're all going
to different places.
I'm not going to go into
that, because that's
a informatics challenge that
at once seems quite simple,
and it is.
The technologies all exist.
It's more of a
sociological challenge,
because it's very, very
hard to enforce this.
So we can actually
reconstitute the data,
in this case about this island.
And it's a very
massive challenge.
And it really involves
applying unique identifies
to all of these objects,
which again, sounds simple,
but in reality it's very
hard to make happen.
Having done that, if you've
got all your list of parts,
that's just the first step.
How are they interacting
with each other?
That's really
what's interesting.
That's kind of the exciting
part, for us as ecologists,
at least.
And that's pivoting
now, as Chris Meyer, who
directed this project at
the Smithsonian, calls it.
We're going from an inventory,
which is going out and finding
things and grinding them
up and sequencing them,
to an approach which is
more observatory over time.
We've got the
reference database.
Now we're actually
going to reverse.
We grind them up, and
then we sequence them,
blast them against our reference
database, and see what we got.
This we can do at high volume.
So we're trying to yank this
science into a science that's
high throughput, which is really
what revolutionized biology,
cellular molecular
biology, is the ability
to get to high throughput
data generation.
Ecology is still painfully slow.
It's hard.
But we're getting to the point
with these new technologies
where we have a
reference database now.
We have these DNA tags.
They're like the license
plates on your car, right?
So now what we need
to decide is, well,
where do we put the toll booths
to read these license plates?
And that's an
ecological question.
How do we understand
who's where in the system,
who are they with?
And potentially
who are they eating
so we can get at things
like the food webs.
Because we can look in the guts.
We can look at plankton trawls.
Because we can just grind
things up and blast it,
sequence and blast it.
And that part's pretty easy.
So it can be done
at high throughput.
And looking at
these interactions,
so for example, now we
can get these DNA tags.
We can look at gut contents.
It gives us a whole new view,
so some of this work Chris Mayer
did with other
partners shown here.
Just as a test, we had
this one cubic foot,
which our National Geographic
photographer David Littschwager
photographed, which there was
a display here a couple years
back.
But can we build a food web
of all of these individuals
that he found in
this one cubic foot
on the coral reef of Moorea?
And so they did that.
So this is what we think all
of those different individuals,
how they might
relate to each other.
You can collapse that down
and say, well, some species
eat the same thing,
so we'll just
collapse that into one node.
It makes it easier to
study for one thing.
But we think they're
doing the same thing.
Here are two species of
fish that were collapsed
into one of those nodes.
And then we can
start to test that.
So we take these guts from these
fish, or rather this team did,
look at what's in those guts.
Obviously they're hard
to identify visually,
so the genetics is really
the only way to get at it.
But what we see here is that
these two fish actually eat
completely different things.
Or at least those
individuals have.
So we were wrong.
Just because they look like
the same fish hanging out
in the same place, probably
eat the same thing,
they seem to be much more
specialized than we thought.
And we can do the same thing
for birds and other organism.
So we start to build
up the interactome,
all the interactions of
this system with evidence,
or at least relatively
direct evidence if it's
found in the gut of something.
And this is sort of part
of a broader revolution,
I would say, in the way
we're looking at ecosystems.
And this is work largely drawing
on Tom Whithams' group who work
on cottonwoods out in Arizona.
And what they've found is that
the genotype of a foundation
species like a tree, the
variation within the species
among individuals,
the genetic variation,
turns out to be
incredibly important
for ecosystem-scale functions.
So treating two
species as if they're
doing the same thing
in the ecosystem
is probably a
dangerous thing to do.
But even saying that species is
all the same is also dangerous.
So when Tom and colleagues
looked at these trees,
they found, for
example, the difference
in elevation of 100 meters or
so can have different genotypes
of tree, which when you put
them in a common garden, which
is what forestry [INAUDIBLE]
have been doing for decades
but not really focused
on natural systems,
when they put them
in common gardens,
whoa-- the ones that are 100
meters higher don't do so well.
And that has all kinds
of knock-on effects also.
This tree, Whitham's group
found that the tree also
has a characteristic set of
insects and bacteria and fungi
and even birds that are linked
to the genotype of the tree.
So trees of the same species
with different genotypes
have different communities.
So there's an extended
phenotype of the tree,
a community-level genomics.
So understanding the genomic
variation within species
can be crucially important,
particularly if they're
foundation species, like trees,
on which a lot of other things
depend.
And the trees have different
variability at elevations.
That's reflecting
environmental adaptation.
So what they've shown, too,
is that if you replant trees
in restoration
projects, that you're
planting the wrong genotype.
And often we try
and plant what's
local because we're scared
of invasive species.
And we plant the local
type tree here locally,
because that's good.
That could be very bad.
It could be good
in a stable world,
but in a world of rapid
environmental change,
you spend millions and
millions of dollars replanting
your forest, in 20 years
time, those trees won't
[? slide there ?]
anymore because they're
the wrong genotype.
You should have
gone further south,
picked up ones 1,000
kilometers further south.
That genotype will respond
to the future climate
in your locality.
But for that, we need to have
a sophisticated understanding
of genomic variation,
climate, and what's happening
in the future climate.
And some of these
certain corals, it's
likely to be the same.
We're beginning-- the
first genome sequence
for a tree was the cottonwood.
That's partly how
Whitham's group were
able to advance so rapidly.
Also on land, this
is traditionally
done, common garden approaches.
Corals are the foundation
species of coral reefs,
and we're finding the
variation among corals
is likely to have similar
kinds of consequences.
So if we're going to really
be able to preserve variation,
we might have to think of
things like assisted migration.
These species are not going
to survive on their own
if there's not enough
genetic variation where
they are unless we introduce
types that are able to survive.
So I'm going to finish up there
with a consideration of when
we get finally down
to this end where
we've got a lot of
this other information.
And now we're able to start
quantifying interactions
and modeling them.
And we really
understand processes.
So for the last 10
minutes or so, I'll
talk a little bit about that.
And what we're
trying to do here is
build a model or set
of models that simulate
or describe as accurately as
we can the whole ecosystem,
including the humans in it,
so a social ecological system
ultimately.
So these computational models
of complex entities exist.
So we have them already for
some things, the obvious one
being the cell.
So the cell is the
foundation of biology.
And we understand an
awful lot about the cell
now, up to the
point where we have
an avatar of bacterial cells.
And actually, we can even
artificially synthesize
the genome and
potentially create
a new species of bacteria,
which is being done.
Craig Venter's group
have done that, recoded
and relaunched a cell.
You still need the cell,
but we can artificially
synthesize a new genome,
put it into a cell,
boot the cell back
up, and you've
got a new species
created by humans.
It's inspired by biology.
It's using its biological
still, and it's still
using an actual cell, but
it's still a physical example
of where you can actually
now understand things,
because we can build them.
If you can't build it,
you don't understand it,
as the saying goes.
Well, we can start to build
at least genomes of cells.
We can also build
them in the computer.
So this was the first whole
cell computational model.
And what does that set up?
I mean, in cells,
of course you have
lots of cells in a laboratory.
You can do lots of
things with cells.
But still, it was
considered potentially
revolutionary to be able to have
these silico avatars of cells
where things emerge from
the model or from the avatar
that you didn't expect.
And then you can go and look
in the real world and say, hey,
does that actually happen?
And so it becomes
a discovery tool
for finding out things
back in the real world.
And so it was hailed partly as
sort of a dawn of virtual cell
biology.
Whether it will actually
supplant the need for [? wet ?]
lab is probably doubtful, but
it certainly is enhancing it.
So virtual cells, computational
models of cells exist.
And they're getting more
and more sophisticated.
And now that's including up to
small multicellular organisms.
So this is back
in 2008, saying we
need to move from the cell
level up to interactions
and how communities function.
And so in this paper,
they were talking
about how organisms
interact and move up
to understanding ecosystems
through these sort of network
analysis approaches.
But look at what they
were calling an ecosystem.
It was something
around your tooth.
It's not necessarily
the ecosystem
we're talking
about at our scale.
But what it shows is
we are all ecosystems,
whether it's our body,
buildings, up to the planet.
And specifically at the case
of landscape-scale social
ecological systems, we need to
be able to deliver predictions,
forecasts that policy
can respond to,
if we're going to
hope to maintain
the health of our
societies and our planet,
just as we do at the scale of
our bodies through medicine.
So predicting the
future-- this was in 1769
when Captain Cook came out
and he went all the way
around the world to look
at transitive Venus.
And I won't go into details of
that, but it was coordinated.
It had to be done-- because
the transitive Venus doesn't
happen very often,
every century or so.
You had to be there to
observe from different parts
of the world in order
to estimate the distance
between the Earth and the sun.
That was what it
was being done for.
But they knew back then exactly
when the next transit would
be, in 1769, so it was
arranged to go out there
and observe it
right at that time.
So the prediction
even then in physics,
astronomy, was very accurate.
And the last transit of Venus
was two years ago, I think.
Have I got that right?
Yeah, two years ago.
And we went out to the
same spot in Tahiti
and stood there and
stood on the beach
and waited for the transit of
Venus, along with thousands
of other people who were
there in this big ceremony.
And the last person
to do that was Cook.
So it's pretty remarkable.
And also sitting there, well,
what if this doesn't happen?
This would really shake up
physics, like, it better.
[LAUGHTER]
I hope this happens.
It would be embarrassing
if it didn't.
But of course, it did.
So physics is safe for a while.
[LAUGHTER]
But interesting anecdote
because I like this,
but Captain Cook sent
out Sir Joseph Banks, who
was future-- this expedition
was funded by the Royal Society
from London.
So it was a
scientific expedition.
And he set up his
observatory on Tahiti.
He sent Banks, who was a
botanist, over to Moorea
to observe it from
Moorea just in case
it was cloudy on Tahiti.
And Banks was the first
European to set foot on Moorea.
So it's kind of nice for me
that the first European who
arrived on Moorea was there
as a scientific mission
to set up an observatory,
and, of course,
we're still doing that.
And here's Frank Murphy,
our associate director
at the station.
We're standing right on
the spot where we think
Banks-- this is on Moorea.
It's eroded now,
but this was where
he stood there to observe
the transitive Venus.
So physics is good,
can predict things.
Biology, we can't predict any--
we have general predictions
but with certainly nothing
like the accuracy of this.
But that's always
going to be a case.
We're never going to get
to that level of accuracy.
But we need to make these
forecasts useful forecasts
at various scales.
And so I'll finish
with this, because this
is what we're trying to do now.
We're trying to
integrate all of these
at the genomic level, all
of the different sciences
that we have but
focused on one system.
How do we join those
into an overarching model
that simulates that
system in a useful way?
Can we do that?
And this project, the Island
Digital Ecosystem Avatar
Consortium now has
about 80 scientists
from around the world, including
physicists and astronomers
who are trying to
understand how we would even
set about doing this.
We've had a number of workshops
over the last year or so.
And really, this is
relating to the book's dream
of using genomic information
from cells up to the planet.
How do we do that ultimately
to model the Earth?
That's overwhelmingly
complex, but we're
trying through these
genomic observatory
sites, and Moorea in
particular, to at least get
a handle on these.
We still have to
start at the molecule,
but we only have to go
to the island, which
is a lot less than the planet.
So we're hoping that's
a little more tractable.
But once we can do
that, we have to have
to solve all of
the same problems
that we'll have to solve
everywhere else in the world
and including at
the global scale.
So it's a focus, yes, but it
still has global ramifications.
So I think I'll stop there.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: It certainly
seems clear that some place
like Moorea would
be an ideal place
to start an effort
like this, because it's
relatively self-contained
and relatively isolated.
But you've cited a number of
different kinds of factors,
I mean not counting
the things that
happened when the humans first
arrived and everything got
completely screwed up, but
just on an ongoing basis,
there's the arrival of
new plants and animals.
There are environmental changes
like temperature and acidity
in the oceans and so forth.
And then also since
you excluded microbial,
that's effectively part
of the environment, too.
And any of those three
things, or all of them,
will be changing over time.
Are those things happening
on a long enough time scale
that they won't interfere with
the time scale of your work?
Or alternatively,
is there anything
you have to do to try to keep
particularly the new plants
and animals from arriving
and disrupting you?
NEIL DAVIES: Yes, so I
think yes to both questions.
But of course you're
absolutely right.
Moorea is changing all the
time, and we can't stop that.
We absolutely have to
look at the microbes.
So at present, we've done the
survey of the large organisms,
because those were the
easy ones to do first.
But a lot of work is also taking
place at the microbial level.
The ocean sampling
data I mentioned,
for example, was a microbial
survey of surface sea water,
looking at marine microbes.
So we need to expand that
Biocode Project, the Moorea
Biocode Project, to include the
microbial parts of the system.
To do that, we're going to
focus on foundation species.
Because we can't do
all the microbes.
So as I mentioned,
the trees-- so
what's the genomic
variation in trees?
Because the Biocode Project
was a species-level inventory.
So we have to also look at
population-level variation
among all the different
individuals on the island.
So the inventory part
is far from complete.
We've got a better handle
than we have elsewhere,
but we've got much,
much more to do.
And the next phases, we'll
be looking at key foundation
species, genomic variation
within those species,
and their microbial
associates and the interaction
between those.
We can't stop.
We have the scale
of the island, which
we're trying to understand
and model what's
happening inside the island.
But we have to take all of
the external inputs, which
at least we can measure,
because in an island,
we know what's outside and
what's inside our system.
The drivers from
outside, we're there
taking regional
and global models
and downscaling those
and linking them
to our local models.
So we're not ignoring what's
happening at the larger
scale and different
time scales, but having
to integrate that with what's
happening at the local scale.
So I didn't mean to
imply that we're only
doing the larger species
and ignoring the microbes.
And the global
changes, we absolutely
have to take into account.
But the predictive
models are basically,
can we predict what
this island will
look like in a few decades
under likely scenarios
of environmental change-- that's
one of the simulations we want
to run-- and under likely
scenarios of policy
change and, of course, the
interaction between those two?
So we're not trying to simulate
every possible scenario.
We're trying to simulate a small
number of scenarios that are
relevant and hopefully useful.
MALE SPEAKER: Quick
question here-- so
what kind of collaborations
are you looking to establish?
I heard that you're working
with the Smithsonian, Oxford
University.
Is there any other
field that you would
like people to contact you?
And what's the best
way to get in touch?
And what is the thing
that like your institution
can provide for these
other institutions that
may have like a fruitful
collaboration in the future?
NEIL DAVIES: Yeah,
so absolutely.
So the consortium, the
idea of consortium,
is completely open
to-- the idea is
to make this system available
to study remotely, right?
We're trying to digitize
the whole system,
put it into supercomputers
so it can be studied remotely
but also connecting back
to what observations need
to happen on the real world.
Because it's not
a computer game.
So we need to
model what we think
can generate these
visualizations, simulations,
and then validate those
in our-real world systems.
So it will involve some
work on the ground and teams
on the ground doing
this deployment
of new senses, satellite
imagery, and embedded network
sensing.
Obviously the genomics
has to be done,
at least the collections
have done, locally.
And then the number of
institutions involved,
we have 20 institution
sort of nodes in the Avatar
Consortium at the moment.
ETH Zurich was one of the
founders, as you mentioned,
Oxford, the French
[? CRNS ?] lab.
So it's completely open to
anyone who wants to join,
thinks they have
something to contribute.
And also part of
this is addressing
the sociological
problem I mentioned
earlier of data sharing.
Because the avatar
is going to be open.
The idea is that everyone puts
their data in there, not just
the data, but the models.
And everything else will go
into this infrastructure.
So all of the experiments
should be reproducible
so anyone else in the
world can try them.
You can actually
run new experiments
if you can do those
experiments virtually.
And also, the avatar will
help task us, hey, we're
trying to model this,
but we don't have data
on this aspect of your system.
Can someone somewhere else?
We really need that if somebody
else could go out and look
at the physiology of
this species of coral
or whatever it might be.
So it also helps
identify opportunities.
And we provide
support physically,
because we have the
labs in the field.
But really, this is a call
for collaboration with anyone
who's interested.
MALE SPEAKER: Please
thank Neil Davies.
NEIL DAVIES: Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]